madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de la voie est
libre
en bourgogne trois chiffres pour
introduire cette émission pourra
chiffres issus d'un sondage ipsos publié
mercredi par le monde sciences po et la
fondation jean jaurès lui et pour cent
des français font confiance aux partis
politiques 72% estiment que la plupart
des hommes et des femmes politiques sont
corrompus et 83 % pensent que le système
démocratique fonctionne mal en france
alors c'est de cette défiance dont nous
allons parler dans cette émission avec
nos quatre invités laurent
grandguillaume bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député socialiste de côte-d'or et vous
avez sorti jeudi un livre intitulé la
gauche a perdu sa boussole offrons lui
un gps et dans lequel vous parler
notamment de cette défiance
jean-baptiste lemoyne bourgeot bonjour
vous êtes sénateur de l'yonne et vous
présidez la fédération du parti de l'est
républicain
dans ce département il quemener bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le délégué régional de
nous citoyens alors c'est un mouvement
qui propose de s'affranchir un peu des
baies des partis traditionnels
on va dire et qui lance avec d'autres à
la primaire à des français en vue de la
présidentielle de 2017 et puis lilian
noireau bonjour vous êtes conseiller
régional front national très tôt engagé
dans la vie politique
vous êtes également conseiller municipal
à montceau-les-mines tout à fait alors
vous pouvez poser vos questions à nos
quatre invités sur notre site internet
bourgogne poids france.fr et commentez
l'émission sur twitter hashtag lvl
bourgogne alors on va donc parler de la
méfiance et de la défiance plus
exactement vis-à-vis de la classe
politique en général et de françois
hollande en particulier parce que le
président la république et à 17%
d'opinions favorables cette semaine
c'est le plus impopulaire des présidents
de la vème république et pourtant il ya
eu des bonnes nouvelles cette semaine
plusieurs sur le chômage la croissance
qui repart la vente des sous-marins
qu'on vous expliquer cette défiance et
c'est un peut plus l'arrêter
laurent guyot moi je pense que tu as
partisans la défiance et devient depuis
le phénomène d'abord le fait que les
politiques les responsables politiques
quels qu'ils soient et quels que soient
les partis n'ont pas toujours un
discours de vérité au sens où quand ils
sont confrontés à une difficulté qui ne
peuvent pas par exemple respecter un
engagement
ils ne vont pas toujours expliqué soit
qu'ils se sont trompés saulnier eu un
échec
vous parlez de françois hollande n'ont
globalement je crois de françois
hollande il a dans son bilan il y à la
fois des ombres et des lumières on peut
pas dire que la gauche ou dans le
quinquennat ou françois hollande
tout ce qu'il a fait a fonctionné il
faut être réaliste
des fois ce discours de vérité mais cela
appartient aussi à tous les hommes
politiques et les femmes politiques
quels qu'ils soient et ce discours de
vérité on en manque dans notre pays et
je crois que quand seulement nous sommes
confrontés difficulté il faut expliquer
pourquoi on n'a pas réussi à tenir un
engagement et comment on peut surmonter
ses difficultés et les citoyens ils
attendent cela je crois en tout cas ça
fait partie des premiers éléments
ensuite le sentiment aussi je pense
parfois qu'ont les citoyens que le
politique ne maîtrise plus l'ordre des
choses que les progrès technologiques
vont très vite que le numérique va très
vite et qu'en fin de compte le politique
apparaît un peu comme un pompier qui
courent après les événements et qui est
là pour éteindre des incendies et qui ne
dit plus là où il veut aller on va en
parler de tout ça donc dans cette
émission justement alors plus
particulièrement sur sur françois
hollande vous chantez susman j'imagine
que vous la comprenez vous cette
défiance malgré les quelques signes
positifs qui semble émerger mais
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui je te vends ce
matin nous en faire la preuve qu'ils ont
la capacité à parler les uns les autres
à échanger pour faire en sorte que les
gens aient envie de croire à nouveau et
encore dans l'action politique et donc
moi l'idée c'est pas taper à bras
raccourcis mais mais juste de faire le
constat que françois hollande en 2012 a
été élu effectivement avec avec une
posture en souvient du discours du
bourget mon ennemi c'est la finance avec
comment dire faisant signer ses
ministres des charte d'éthique et de
transparence
et c'est vrai que après on se retrouve
avec quoi du point de vue de l'électorat
de gauche
on se retrouve avec parfois des réformes
sont différentes de celles qu'ils
attendaient la version 1 de la loi
travail allait sûrement dans le bon sens
pour déverrouiller un certain nombre de
choses de libérer les énergies
effectivement c'était pas ce
qu'attendait son électorat en corée
discours tient de gras trans d'impôt
discours est donc à part ce moment il ya
ce hiatus
effectivement il ya ce sentiment pour
l'électorat d'être floués et ce qui
accrédite bien effectivement une sorte
de désintérêt pour la chose publique
maintenant moi je crois que plus
globalement si on regarde on fait face
aussi avec l'irruption des réseaux
sociaux avec je dire des médias qui
maintenant se déploie de façon très
large on est dans l'immédiateté et c'est
vrai que il ya une difficulté je pense
pour tous les gouvernants et pour tous
les gouvernements d'ailleurs c'est pas
propre à la france en europe
comment arriver à montrer un cap à
garder une cohérence dans l'action alors
que l'actualité est balayée d'un jour
sur l'autre et pour prendre un exemple
très concret lorsque jacques chirac en
95 faisait une conférence de presse
président de la république
cette conférence de presse quelque part
elle vivait pendant je pense une semaine
quinze jours on veut dire véritablement
cela alimente l débat public aujourd'hui
françois hollande ou hier nicolas
sarkozy faisait un point bas font un
point presse la durée 10 et 24 heures
parce que derrière on va vous sortir la
dernière phrase de nabila pardon mais
c'est la vie mais c'est comme ça et donc
savoir bonne qualité non mais et donc
nous il faut qu'on arrive à trouver des
solutions pour contrer ces phénomènes là
qui font que tout est mis sur le même
plan
or je suis désolée la parole du
président la république quel qu'il soit
c'est pas le même plan que la parole de
nabila mon père je crois que je crois
qu'il faut pas faire non plus du holland
dashing comme on a fait du sarkozy
beijing pendant c'est quand même ce qui
remirent dix ans
la défiance que l'on a aujourd'hui est
la conséquence est ce que disait laurent
grandguillaume la conséquence de trente
ans ou 35 ans de mensonges répétés de
gauche comme de gauche comme de droite
de tous les gouvernements qui n'ont
jamais su où jamais pu prendre les
véritables les véritables décisions et
la défiance amont à mon sens je vais
prendre trois trois exemples très très
rapide on dit par rapport à la loi
travail par exemple
il faut que les salariés ne travaillent
pas trop longtemps et cetera il faut
réduire la qualité de vie très bien mais
les kabyes dans les cabinets
ministériels
les membres des cabinets ministériels
font 80 90 heures de travail par de
travail par semaine et c'était et ce
sont eux qui disent il faut travailler
il faut travailler moi qui commence par
se l'appliqué deuxième
deuxième exemple la retraite je me
tourne les deux parlementaires demandent
il faut effectivement des récentes d'une
réforme de la retraite beaucoup plus
virulente et ces messieurs commencer par
parfaire la réforme de votre régime
spécial
comment voulez vous que les gens vous
fassent confiance qu'à partir du moment
où vous leur dites très bien fait des
efforts mais nous pour l'instant on n'en
sait pas près d'y résister quoi il un
troisième exemple qui est qui et qui est
tout à fait frappant avec dans une
entreprise on doit avoir 6 % de salariés
handicapés et si on a passé 6 % on est
on est on est amendée aujourd'hui dans
la fonction publique toutes fonctions
publiques confondues
on doit être à deux et demi on doit être
à deux et demi pour cent donc que le que
l'état et et au travers de l'état les
élus des partis traditionnels commencent
déjà par ce s'appliquer à eux-mêmes ce
qu'ils près que ce qu'il préconise pour
les autres l'exemplarité crime en
faisant des tours de table et si on
discute heures
les lions de bar ou sur certains vols il
a été précisément du chef de l'état elle
vous semble légitime évidemment alors
cette défiance qu'ont les français
vis-à-vis de françois hollande est
totalement légitime comme il l'avait
d'ailleurs allé garde de nicolas sarkozy
sarkozy hollande bonnet blanc blanc
bonnet c'est simplement des mandats des
chèques de renoncement prenons le cas de
monsieur sauvadet votre collègue
monsieur lemoine françois sauvadet
durant la campagne des régionales
s'était engagé à démissionner de son
mandat de député six élus à la région
que ce soit à la tête de la présidence
ou simple conseiller régional excusez
moi mais il a toujours pas démissionné
donc c'est quand même derrière
d'ailleurs j'invite tous les
bourguignons les francs comtois qui nous
regardent à se rendre sur le site
change.org et signer la pétition qui a
été lancée par ce film hôtel pour exiger
la démission de monsieur sauvadet
c'était déjà de ses engagements à
renoncement légitime et une défiance
tout à fait légitime vis-à-vis des
partis traditionnels du gouvernement
comme vous aimez les appeler monsieur
hollande
qu'at-il fait on va retenir quoi de son
mandat le mariage pour tous et après on
va retenir le chômage pour tous les
attentats
voilà c'est ça le bilan de françois
hollande alors quand j'entends monsieur
grandguillot ir l'épaule du contrat je
vous ai pas loupé si vous voulez dire
que je ne vous ai pas plomber donc
j'aimerais également pouvoir terminer
monsieur ben rien s'il vous plaît
quand j'entends monsieur grandguillaume
durera les politiques cours sont les
pompiers mais vous êtes les pyromanes
c'est vous qui avez mis le feu dans
l'est dans les quartiers c'est vous avec
vos politiques dites de la ville
c'est vous qui êtes et responsable alors
que vous offusquez aujourd'hui les
français sont défiants vis-à-vis des
politiques mais c'est votre faute
alors si vous n'y arrivez pas mais
laisser la place arrêtez arrêtez laisser
la place à ceux qui veulent vraiment
travailler pour la santé
ce qu'on veut dire par rapport à trading
ce noir ou est ce que finalement il ya
eu des réformes à la est un exemple
inaudible dire que par exemple les
attentats c'est le
on est que certains bilans françois
hollande franchement c'est une
caricature de la politique que de dire
ça pourquoi parce que les attentats
c'est pas le bihan françois hollande
s'est hélas ils ont touché à la fois la
france et les français et nous sommes
tous justement normalement ensemble à
combattre le terrorisme et ce n'est pas
le bilan en fin de compte d'un ou un
autre c'est notre pays qui a été frappé
un stage de cirque quand même à dire
vous savez par rapport à ce que vous
dites ou vont vous parler pendant de
francs soit sauvegardée par rapport au
cumul des mandats mais ce que je
constate aussi c'est que même dans votre
propre parti vous avez des élus qui
cumulent vous vous dites il faut changer
la politique et en même temps vous avez
en quelque sorte avec les différentes
victoires que vous avez eu à certaines
élections
et bien maintenant des parlementaires
qui sont issus également élus locaux
donc c'est un élément à prendre en
compte parce que vous ne l'avez vous
l'appliquez soit non plus vos sur l'a64
suffisant vous parlez d'ex-aequo prenons
l'exemple des mandats quand je me suis
piqué le non cumul des mandats avec un
exécutif local et démission de l'adjoint
au maire de dix présidents
d'agglomérations et de conseil général
quand j'ai été élu député
moi même je les difficultés à défendre
non cumul dans ma propre famille
politique puisque la loi qui était
adoptée s'applique en 2017 et je crois
qu'il faudra justement qu'elles soient
respectées par tous et qu'elle fasse
l'objet d'une je l'espère une unité
nationale il faudra aller plus loin dans
le nom tourner dans le temps aussi à
deux mandats consécutifs
mais on voit bien la difficulté à
avancer sur ce sujet parce que c'est sûr
que les élus en place sont pas forcément
s'appliquait toujours ce qu il justement
propose cote à la retraite des
parlementaires
il ya déjà une première réforme il faut
aller plus loin effectivement je pense
pas qu'à avoir un régime spécial soit
une bonne chose et vous avez raison
qu'on s'adresse à participer aussi
parfois une forme de décrédibilisation
au sens quand on demande des efforts aux
françaises et aux français il faut aussi
savoir bien sûr on devrait commencer par
en faire pour soi-même
je suis après il faut aussi quand même
pour les élus permettre et je pense un
statut de l'élu qui offrirait en
particulier aux citoyens qui viennent du
privé la possibilité de pouvoir se
présenter aussi à des élections parce
que là aussi il n'y a pas assez de
diversité je pense
du point de vue social
au sein des élus oui alors une réaction
parce que on parle de sentiment de
défiance croissante est liée au bilan du
gouvernement mais il ya quand même
quelque chose qui me fait un peu mal au
coeur c'est le fait qu'on a un
gouvernement qui d'une part a conduit à
faire des régions xxl très grande et
également des intercommunalités très
grande et du coup c'est vrai que la
figure du maire qui est dans la commune
l'élu de proximité et bien ce maire il
voit ses pouvoirs
diluez transféré pour beaucoup et je
trouve que justement de ce point de vue
là le gouvernement a peut-être pas rendu
service à la proximité au rôle des élus
locaux et parce que ce sont eux sur
lesquelles repose cette république puis
il ya mathieu roy qui nous envoie
plusieurs questions à d'ailleurs à ce
sujet et qui a suscité beaucoup là
dessus c'est d'abord le téléspectateur
donc les français rejettent leurs
politiques nationaux mais ils respectent
leurs élus locaux
or depuis de nombreuses années ont
détruit ce lien de proximité dit alors
qu'elle plaçait ce que vous accordez aux
élus de proximité et surtout est-ce que
vous sauvegarde degré l'échelon communal
qui semble quand même menacé par les
différentes réformes lieux critique par
rapport aux cibles il faut avoir un
regard critique sur ce qui a été fait
dans l'autre les grandes régions en tout
cas si nécessaire d'avoir des régions je
pense en tout cas plus forte au niveau
national et au niveau européen après
l'intercommunalité c'est une bonne chose
de pouvoir se regrouper pour avoir des
compétences communes
et puis répondre aux besoins des
citoyens mais c'est vrai que la commune
en fin de compte on la critique beaucoup
en décembre il faut réguler au mieux
comme une autre commune en france
sata partie de notre histoire et en plus
cette année a effectivement de proximité
de notre foi la garder et je prends oui
mais je crois qu'il faut la garder
après que des communes décident ensemble
de fusionner c'est leur choix assez
démocratique front train de le faire
mais je crois que la commune est
également c'est un joueur de proximité
sont souvent poussés à le faire selon
manque aujourd'hui entre pays ce sont
des médiations changement social dans
les territoires là où parfois et bien
l'éducation populaire a reculé les liens
ont reculé et je pense que la commune
c'est vraiment le lieu de la médiation
est une réponse très rapide sauf que en
matière de collectivités locales et là
je parle plutôt des colliers des
communautés d'agglo
c'est la ville centre en fait qui
détient la totalité du pouvoir
et c'est là où les citoyens se sentent
se sentent bernés que ça soit les 70 à
peu près 70 conseillers communautaires
de la ville de de la ville de dijon
il doit y avoir il doit y avoir 30 35 35
contre il est issu de la ville
directement de la ville de divo
forcément que les décisions qui sont
prises au niveau de la communauté
d'agglo sont les décisions de la ville
de la ville de dijon et c'est pas
simplement à dijon à besançon séparé il
ya dans toutes les communautés dans
toutes les communautés d'agglo péril ses
entretiens à rome oui alors c'est moins
c'est moins vrai dans les communautés de
communes où il ya un véritable travail
de collaboration entre les communes mais
cette loi notre elle a été créée par des
parisiens et qui ne connaissent pas au
fait connaissez l'expression derrière le
derrière le périphérique cd sauvage quoi
mais c'est des gens la plupart du temps
qui ne connaisse qui ne connaissent pas
la réalité de la ruralité comme comme le
département de l'yonne par exemple on a
quand même à sa chance à sept députés
ont semble-t-il un certain nombre de
sénateurs qui ont voté quand on est dans
l'appui quand on est quand un avis dans
la dans la puisaye voulez-vous dire
qu'est ce que l'on a de commun avec
quelqu'un qui habite dans le sud dans le
sud revermont du jura
rien du tout rien du tout en commun ni
culturellement ni économiquement il n'y
a absolument rien en commun
donc comment voulez vous que les
citoyens moi je reviens sur votre sur le
sondage que vous avez cités au départ
comment voulez vous plais que des
citoyens aient une quelconque intérêt
année à quelconque intérêt aujourd'hui
pour la chose publique là pour la
république
et pourtant c'est notre travail de tous
les jours donc je viens 10 ans et j'ai
vécu à montceau-les-mines nouvelle donc
et en fait je pense qu'il ya quand même
des éléments communs entre la bourgogne
et la franche-comté et je crois que le
fait que cette grande région elles
construisent un projet commun qu'elles
avancent de concert entre les
territoires ruraux urbains interurbains
pour moi c'était un bon c'est pas con au
sujet du jeu au grain répondra encore à
monsieur grandguillaume ça m'étonne de
la bouche d'un élu socialiste de parler
de la commune puisque je vous rappelle
quand même que la loi nôtre c'est
simplement la langue de risa sion vous
êtes vous avez subi et appliqué le dit à
bruxellois alors que nous au front
national on défend quand même l'identité
locale est un triptyque qu'elle
s'arrêterait fonctionne et qui
fonctionne s'il vous plaît c'est la
commune le département et la nation
l'état les intercommunalités c'est quoi
c'est simplement des gabegies si on
donne de l'argent donne de l'argent
place les copains monsieur a perdu
élections municipales une prendre le cas
de montceau-les-mines parce que vous
n'arrêtez pas quitter mon saut
d'ailleurs je t'invite à à revenir à
montceau enverrait comme jury ville est
régulièrement donc à montceau les mines
on a le cas de la mairie socialiste de
l'ancien maire monsieur mathus qui était
battu et à la communauté de communes on
a replacé le copain qui est ancien
conseiller général qui est élu à la
ville de montceau de l'ami vice
président comme celle des recasés donc
l'inter comme il dit c'est simplement
une gabegie et du copinage
alors la loi ne sais quoi la loi nôtre
c'est simplement encore cette grande
fusion qui n'apporte rien ils
n'apportent pas d'économie et qui fait
au contraire encore mal au portefeuille
des français et pour parler des
bourguignons des francs comtois madame
buffet votre collègue socialiste à la
région a quand même mené ans qui n'a pas
prôner d'ailleurs aucune aucune économie
l'a dit hier revenant sur la déception
je termine simplement mais la défiance
est celle ci durant la campagne des
régionales on ne l'a jamais entendu dire
qu'elle allait augmenter le tarif des
cartes grises et maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
hier qu'est ce que la majorité
socialiste a fait hier elle a indexé le
tarif de la carte grise de cheval fiscal
qui était de 51 euros hambourg
agne et 36 euros en france en franche
comté la dexc hauteur de 51 euros
les francs-comtois grâce à vous encore
devoir payer plus est la commune la
commune là on a une grande différence et
c'est pas important qui est des clivages
commencé que vous défendez l'identité
locale et je vois que l'identité c'est à
dire une quantité reliés à la sécurité
reliés à l'immigration c'est à dire si
le corse usine de l'egypte du front
national c'est le club alors là je sais
mais il faut rappelle les choses c'est
parce que c'est comme ça moi je sais que
je défends c'est plutôt gris série la
commune ministre il mène au bureau des
france et les acquis de la commune en
venant gagner la tolérance étrangères
dit ce monsieur jean guilhas en veux
rappeler c'est pas que vivre ensemble
c'est aussi faire ensemble et je ne suis
pas sûr que vous défendiez cela parce
que quand vous dites que vous défendez
la commune on doit pas défendre la même
commune quand même je maîtriserai les
intérêts nommé citoyen moi je crois que
voilà il est impératif de garder pour
garder la confiance des français
ce lien entre l'élu et les électeurs et
ce lien il passe on le voit au niveau de
la commune par quand même une confiance
qui est donnée au maire et à sa liste et
pour les élections quand même au scrutin
majoritaire
moi je crois beaucoup aux vertus de ce
scrutin parce que le l'élu est
responsable
m alors que quand on va sur des scrutins
proportionnels qui sont appelé de leurs
voeux d'ailleurs par le front national
ou par d'autres partis qui dit doit se
faire une place au soleil grâce à ça ça
dit lui la responsabilité et c'est vrai
que à l'échelon régional c'est un peu ça
d'ailleurs on peut voir que lorsque les
partis protestataires
son candidat aux élections à la
proportionnelle ils font souvent des
gros scores mais quand il s'agit de
donner les clés du camion et est de
faire confiance au niveau d'une élection
municipale
on voit que vous divisez votre part 2
c'est simple cela démissionner mais là
on apporte des solutions et quand on
apporte des solutions
et bien c'est vrai que les gens
retrouvent confiance est donc certain
que moi je dis il faut pas non plus
tomber dans un discours aux lieux moi
parce que j'ai entendu et j'ai entendu
des shoots foyen sur ses lacets les
avantages des élus etc
il ya cinq cent mille élus locaux en
france les retraites hectares il ya cinq
cent mille locaux c'est sûr que ça
repose et eux ils coûtent pas cher parce
que les trois quarts sont bénévoles et
en réalité moi quand je siège au sénat
je suis avant tout un élu local qui est
envoyé par ses pairs pour faire en sorte
que les politiques qui sont élaborés des
décisions qui sont prises soient éminent
respectueuse de fait de ce fait là voilà
c'est pas du tout ce que l'on dit au
niveau des élus locaux simple simplement
vous avez raison mais seulement à un
haut niveau du du scrutin du scrutin
majoritaire alors à une seule condition
c'est que la plupart du temps dans l'est
dans les élections locales des élections
municipales en particulier puisque ce
sont des scrutins de liste si celui qui
a au deuxième tour 51 pour 51%
s'il prenait plus en compte celui qui a
fait 49 ça serait ça marcherait quand
même beaucoup mieux
regardez bien et que je prends le
rendront guillaume à témoin puisque là
il a pris cette responsabilité c'était
très bien quand quand françois hollande
est arrivé au gouvernement
première mesure qui l'a fait cai aimant
la première suppression des de
l'exonération de charges sur les heures
supplémentaires
c'était vraiment une une position
totalement idéologique contre laquelle
nous
c'est une coquille on va pas revenir sur
ça car désormais j'aimerais qu'on veut
qu'on revienne quand même sur le climat
actuel on voit notamment lors des
manifestations contre la loi travail de
nombreux débordements et c'est ça sa
part pas aussi du même principe est ce
que ça veut dire quelque chose selon
vous sur le climat actuel date de oued
défiance encore une fois vis-à-vis de la
classe politique
je pense que la défiance l'appelle aussi
des solutions c'est pas uniquement faire
le constat de la déférence oui il ya
deux ans des tensions sociales il ya des
tensions politiques
ce qu'il faut je crois c'est
concrètement un le non cumul dans le
temps deux mandats successifs maximum
d'eux s'est tiré au sort 10% des
assemblées délibérantes c'est ce coup
comme les départements régions c'est ce
que je propose un livre parmi les
citoyens qui sont inscrits ce risque
sera l'heure de manière à ce que dans
l'ensemble des assemblées délibérantes
on est des citoyens qui ne sont pas
forcément membres de partis politiques
soient tirés au sort et qui participe
aux débats en fait est qu'ils puissent
justement par leurs interventions
oser des questions aussi sur l'exécution
sur les projets et qu'en même temps à
être force de proposition et puis après
il faudrait aller plus loin
moi je propose aussi que par exemple on
puissent fusionner le sénat et le
conseil économique social et
environnemental
mais au moins ayant le débat pourquoi
pas territoires représentés également
les forces sociales
on parle des tensions sociales les
forces économiques mais en tout cas on
peut avoir ce débat je pense qu'il est
important mais on peut encore aller plus
loin je sur d'autres sujets je vais vous
donner un bulletin d'adhésion à nos
citoyens
je vais me permettre de répondre à
monsieur à monsieur lemoine concernant
déjà la proportionnelle en fait ce qui
vous fait peur avec la professeure avec
la proportionnelle cette paire nos
petits avantages ans et s'y attendait
les ce matin c'est que quand vous allez
vous allez réussir a indiqué m landreau
majoritaire regarder à fréjus les
municipalités regardez aux dernières
élections départementales ou
nous avons fait élire plusieurs dizaines
de conseillers départementaux la
proportionnelle vous fait parler d'eux
bien d'autres d'ailleurs et c'est moi
c'était ta gueule c'était pour terminer
révèle la parole des électeurs avoir n'a
fait élire à pino dans l'yonne on prend
ce binôme n'existe plus vous pourriez
mais ces terminaux mais non mais c'est
s'intéresser sa montre mais je vais y
aller langue allemande et des candidats
du front national voilà alors la
proportion à leur salaire fait peur
puisqu'ils ont réussi à mettre le pied
dans la fourmilière et mettre un bon
coup de dent ça leur permet de casser
leurs petits avantages et leur petite
routine
pourquoi lors des dernières régionales
les socialistes sont retirés en paca
dans le nord pour faire front contre le
front national et pour s'allier à l'ump
ça démontre d'ailleurs parfaitement le
mps patron d'emaar est avec nous sommes
républicains comme dans le monde et on
peut même y va pour faire parler tous en
même temps orgueilleuse france messieurs
les différences et d'idéaux parler
j'aimerais également vous exprimer dans
le respect mais la proportionnelle ça
vous fait peur c'est tout pas d'accord
pourtant les pensionnaires
mais la vraie force hier sa conduite coi
n'entend 5 11 8
justement est-ce que et bien on est des
élus est fort sympathique mais qui se
contente juste de débuter
l'argumentaire de leur thème national
moi ce que je souhaite c'est plutôt des
élus locaux qui sont enracinés justement
ont fait leur secondaire 28 morts et un
autre des actions concrètes
attendez vous connaissez chacun peut
s'exprimer du front national
nous avons visité monde arte est ce que
vos élus du front national sont prêts à
s'attaquer non le nombre des mandats
c'est moi sans attendre les six mois
mais oui mais oui ça nous sommes sur un
plateau télé oui alors que nous
représentons chacun la réalité des
réunions des faucons foyers français
donc laissez moi témoin et dernier
terminée mais rapidement mais fonderie
mais je pourrais également fait terminer
monsieur m avait laurent gaudé donc de
faire la fête
oui c'est laissez-moi vous à répondre on
a compris que vous étiez pour la
proportionnelle
est ce que nous attendions des mandats
mais bien sur bayonne mais bien sûr donc
j'applique non mais sur sur cette
proportionnelle c'est la stat ou non un
ami françois hollande à françois
françois hollande lors des
présidentielles en 2012 l'avait mis dans
son programme instauré une dose de
proportionnelle
est ce qui vous fait peur avec ce rêve
proposent cette proportionnelle c'est
simplement le fait de laisser s'exprimer
les français et pouvoir donner les
moyens aux français d'avoir des very
d'avoir des députés des sénateurs à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat qui soit
front national c'est tout ce qui vous
fait peur et c'est encore un des
renoncements de françois hollande
un de ses engagements d'antan de voir
deux fois quand on parle d un modèle pur
et simple simplement qu'on se trompe pas
monsieur - les françaises n'ont pas de
défiance et de méfiance vis-à-vis des
élus locaux
bien qu'aucun parti pour ta bien oui
mais le problème c'est le trottoir qui
est à refaire la mamie qui a mal
traversé c'est pas le cépage est pas un
problème
le pôle la défiance et les vis-à-vis du
pouvoir paris enfin on va dire entre
guillemets du pouvoir parisien même
parlementaire
je partage ici pour avoir admis à suivre
la décision de la commission
et quand je pense quand je vous écoute
tous les deux il ya plein de plein de
points que je reprendrai à mon compte je
vais être obligé de vous intéresse
parce que là vous me redonnerait
l'apparent allez je vous donnerai d
après les arbres et les envoyer parce
que effectivement on va voir